it sounded like you
you sort of changed your
your network to a pretty significant
degree as you were making your wounds
your work like
there there were obviously people that
you had to let go of like how did you
make those decisions like i call these
anchors and sales right like there's
people that are anchors that are going
to hold you back that you got to cut
loose and there's of course sales that
will you know you you uh you know you
cast up and it fills with win and it you
know takes your next port of call sort
of thing like how did you how did you go
through the process of deciding you know
like who's who's going to come along for
the ride and who you got to let go of
i i didn't have anybody in my circle at
that point i really didn't anybody worth
having in my circle anyways
you know i mean
that's not entirely fair you know i had
i had family members and things who
cared about me you know things like that
but that's not what i'm referring to
uh
you know what i actually started doing
is not eliminating people from my life
but being very conscious about who i
wanted in my life and so i started
attending conferences and started
reaching out to people and connecting
with them on social media
going to events creating my own events
and then i just realized through
through that process i started to look
around and i'm like man i don't have any
losers in my circle
not because i actively cut them out but
because i was actively pursuing the
right kind of people in high caliber men
in my corner and then the other thing i
would say is trying to be valuable to
those guys
like i didn't feel
i felt really inadequate initially when
i was trying to spend time with these
high achievers and the men i was
inspired by and and looked up to
but
i i realized if i don't belong here then
i got to figure out a way to belong here
and what can i do i can add value
the thing that i did yeah the thing that
i did
is i just started making introductions i
mean like i
i didn't have anything personally i felt
like i could add but i would listen hey
rich needs he has this problem he needs
an introduction and and joe over here
has this problem but he can solve riches
so like what if i sync these guys up and
i started becoming
frankly at the risk of sounding arrogant
an incredible networker and i was
listening for problems
i was listening for people who provided
solutions and then i was learning how to
make those connections in the most
effective way and then just get out of
the way like that's it just let the
chips fall where they may and get out of
the way and i've done that tens if not
hundreds of thousands of times at this
point and i've become pretty invaluable
in in some people's lives because i'm a
champion for them i look for their
problems and i help them solve those
problems through connections i might not
be able to fix anything but i can make a
connection to somebody who can how did
you figure out the importance of making
those connections like
when was that you know like epiphany
moment like the frying pan of the
forehead like wow this is important this
actually opens doors
i i don't know if there was a moment
where i'm like oh this'll work because
that almost sounds like you're gaming it
and it might sound like i'm gaming it
now as you're listening to this but
you just have to care about people
like that's it i i shouldn't have to say
that but it seems like i do especially
in this like over
marketing digitized world of trying to
like game and manipulate every
relationship that you have for your
benefit but like i care about people you
know i i want people to win i want to
see him thrive just like you said you
watch that video you didn't know me at
the time but you're like man i hope this
guy makes it because you care about
people
and if you care about people then you're
going to get your own ego out of the way
and your own pride i will say that got
in the way there was times where i'm
like okay i'm going to keep score like i
introduced rich to joe and they did this
deal and now joe and rich owe me
man that doesn't that doesn't equate to
care that's manipulation that's like i
it's not even a gift like i'm trying to
get something from you
so i don't know i just i've always cared
about people you know i was raised by
primarily a single mother
um and
and bless her heart she she's one of the
most caring people i know so maybe i
learned it from her
i remember one story that we had this um
we had this postman he was he was kind
of a jerk i remember him being a jerk
and uh and my mom i don't know why i
remember this story but my mom like made
it her mission
to make that guy her friend
and he just seemed miserable i remember
that as a young kid but she would on
holidays like give him a plate of
cookies or put a cake out for him when
he when he brought the mail
and over time man sure enough like he
became such a pleasant person to be
around and he would smile and he would
greet us and i'm like whoa this is cool
and i think that's quite an epiphany
moment for me of just treating people
well
and letting the results and the chips
fall where they may when you do
i i you know since you brought up that
thing about being raised by um by your
mom like what happened to your dad
uh so my dad and mom split when i was
about three years old
uh unfortunately he got into drugs and
alcohol
and my mom decided you know she didn't
want to raise me and my sister in that
environment to her credit of course
because i think it would have been
easier in a lot of ways for her to stick
around and stay and just keep us in that
environment but she pulled us from that
environment
my dad's a good man you know we had our
man we had a lot of a lot of challenges
in our relationship he died actually
three years ago
unfortunately and i
he was in the hospital my mom called me
in long story short um
i was i was driving to go see him and
she calls me about 30 minutes out she's
like where are you i'm like i'm coming i
got there he died 30 minutes before i
got there
you know and so um man i never got to
say goodbye there's a lot of things that
were unsaid between us um and in another
life you know we'll have those
conversations
uh there's a lot of redeeming qualities
about him but you know a lot of things
that uh i think he could have done
better and i think if he'd be here in
this conversation right now he'd
probably say the same thing so i'm
trying to
i'm trying to redeem i don't know this
is a weird i haven't talked about it
like this but i'm trying to redeem
myself and in a way trying to redeem him
and live for him and the decisions that
i think in another life he would have
made differently did he spend much time
with you when you're growing up or was
it most of your mom yeah i was mostly my
mom but you know we lived in
in different areas of the state
california and then i moved to utah so i
didn't see him a whole lot but i saw him
about once a year maybe twice a year
not a lot but man we had some good times
you know we built pinewood derby cars
together and did legos together and
watched uh american gladiator together
that was a big one like
wwe yeah man um
so like we had a reason your
relationship year old that's not on uh
trt apparently
yeah that's right um we had a good a
good enough relationship as you could
when you only see your father once a
year twice a year maybe
and like one of the things that i've
noticed as a general trend because i've
because i've coached um
probably well over a thousand guys now
like one-on-one whenever there's a guy
that's been raised by a single mom
it always seems like they start life
from
a position of um
they're missing something right like
it's a bit of a disadvantage you know
they're uh softer they're a little more
beta they're more accommodating they're
humble to a fault
um did you find yourself um in a
position when you came into your like
teen years you know like
young adulthood where you had to sort of
like figure that out like how do i how
do i uh reconcile you know dealing with
this feminine influence growing up with
this need to be a man
i didn't i didn't feel it to that level
when i was a kid um i do remember
vividly having a very hard time relating
with other young men like even my
friends and i had friends you know i was
social football i played sports i don't
know i just didn't feel confident man
like i always felt like just some
underlying level of inadequacy or i
wasn't like cool enough or
you know i didn't belong there and i was
kind of just a visitor and just
partaking but not really part of the
club you know
i didn't feel like i was part of the
tribe i kind of felt like the token guy
who's just like kind of hovering around
and you know but i was a popular kid i
was athletic you know so from the
outside looking in you'd think oh that
guy's got it all figured out and i had
some real self-esteem issues i mean even
ten years ago maybe even less even
having this conversation with you i'd be
intimidated by it you know and i think a
lot of these guys that grow up with
overly feminine influences in their
lives misinterpret assertiveness
strength uh conviction for you know
being an [ __ ] or or overbearing or
dominant and i don't see that anymore
because i've been able to build that
confidence over time where i look at
somebody like yourself or other people
i've had interactions with and think i'm
not intimidated like i'm impressed you
know i'm inspired
and i love having conversations like
this
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you